according to a report from the new  republic you have democratic groups  including by the way  nancy pelosi's majority political action  committee that are actually out there in  this country running ads  trying to promote  extremist republican candidates because  they somehow think that if we promote  the extremists and then they get on the  primary or they make it past the primary  get on the general ballot  then hey that's going to drive people to  the democrats right  because that worked so well  in 2016 when when the democratic party  promoted trump  because they thought he'd be the easiest  to beat  and for the record technically you know  popular vote hillary clinton did beat  him but we don't go by popular vote we  go by electoral college  so that doesn't mean a whole heck of a  lot  the problem is these democratic groups  are playing with fire